the goal of this video is to introduce
you to the idea of learning plans on
khan academy and i'm going to focus on a
plan for sixth grade math but what i'm
talking about is as applicable to fourth
grade math as it is to sixth grade math
as it is to something like calculus or
statistics
now the core of any learning plan is the
course you're actually working on and so
if i were to click on sixth grade math
year i would go right over here to the
sixth grade course on khan academy in
order to make sense of the learning plan
you really first need to make sense of
how is a course structured on khan
academy every course is subdivided into
units you can see the units listed on
the left here ratios rates and
percentages arithmetic operations so on
and so forth you also see them listed on
the right here and on the right they are
broken down into the various lessons
now you have two things going on you
have a certain number of mastery points
for the entire course and then you have
a certain number of mastery points for
that unit and as we'll see in the
learning plan we're going to talk about
how you can pace yourself through these
units and what are some target mastery
point goals you could have for the units
in a given week so if we go back to the
plan itself there's some text that
explains how to do it but what it
essentially says is
here is the plan and we give several
plans one that can occur over 20 weeks
and then another that can occur over 12
weeks and we say week by week what unit
should you be working on and then how
many mastery points should you target
getting at least and there's space for
you to write down or type in at the end
of the week how many mastery points did
you get which you might want to share
with your parents or your teacher and so
if you just keep doing that over in this
case those 20 weeks then by the end of
that you will have a good understanding
of sixth grade math now at the end we
have something called the course
challenge and we also talk about earlier
in this plan that you might want to
start by taking these course challenges
so what are we talking about well if you
go to a course if you go to the bottom
you see course challenge here and if i
click there it's going to scroll down
right over there and it says start
course challenge and when i start there
it's going to give me 30 questions
that'll take me 30 to 45 minutes that
are sampling items from throughout the
course given that many of you have
already completed a good chunk of the
school year this is a great place to
start because it can give you
accelerated credit for things you
already know and it can help you
understand the things that you don't
know the things that you do know you're
start going to start getting leveled up
in and to understand what it means to
get leveled up we can go into this first
unit that i've already started working
on and you could see skill by skill it
has a sense of whether you are familiar
proficient or mastered depending on how
many of these stacked blocks you
actually get so if you already know a
lot of a given grade level or a lot of a
given course i recommend taking the
course challenge and if you get 70 or
better take it again and again that'll
really accelerate your mastery points
and give you credit for a lot of skills
so then you can focus on the ones that
you don't know and then the ones that
you don't know you can then go to those
particular units and take the unit tests
in them and just to get a sense of what
the unit tests look like let's go to
this first unit again
and if you click here in the bottom left
on unit test it'll scroll down to the
bottom of the page and you can say start
unit test and a unit test you can kind
of view it as a course challenge that's
just focused on that unit so once again
if you feel like you already know a
particular unit you could take the unit
test over and over again you're going to
get different questions and that's a
faster way to get leveled up mastery now
going back to sixth grade you might have
noticed this thing called a mastery
challenge a mastery challenge allows
your skills to get leveled up and these
are skills that you might have gotten
familiar recently or they're making sure
that you've reviewed skills that you've
seen in the past
so going back to the plan
start with a course challenge and then
the appropriate unit tests and as much
as possible try to keep pace with these
points right over here
now for some reason you fall behind not
a big deal and if for some reason you
feel like jumping around that is okay
too this is all about helping you the
student be in the driver's seat of your
own learning now for those of you who
are feeling a little bit less confident
we're also providing for each grade
level ways to build your foundations so
this is what we're calling the super
ultra strong foundation learning plan
for in this case students completing
sixth grade and there we say hey in
parallel to trying to finish sixth grade
try to do the same thing with our
arithmetic course and if you are a sixth
grader taking the arithmetic course a
lot of it is going to be review so once
again take those course challenges as
many times as you like if you're getting
70 or over you're likely to really be
able to accelerate what you do know and
then you'll know where your gaps are and
you can focus on those units
now in each of the plans for either the
grade level or for the foundational work
we have both 20-week plans that i just
showed you and we have a 12-week plan
the 12-week plan focuses a little bit
more on the essentials of the course
while the 20-week plan is a bit more
comprehensive so think about which one
works best for you and think about
whether you need just the grade level
course or in parallel to do the
foundational work as well but either way
all of us here at khan academy are
confident that if you stay focused you
keep up with these plans that over the
course of the school closures and the
summer you're going to build a really
strong foundation in your mathematics
and you'll be off to a great start next
school year